Okay, I think we'll get started today.
Thank you all for coming. The title of this session is...
Where'd we go? Let's see.
Not advancing.
We're having some slide issues.
There we go. Okay, so the title of this session is Where Expected
Pathways, Innovation, Safety, and Patient Access
Collide. And we're going to use the new KRAS inhibitor
drugs as an example of really trying to get a
discussion going, a starting discussion on do we have
the right clinical trials for the types of drugs, these
targeted agents, that are now showing a lot of activity even
in the early phase one trials? And so one of the issues,
of course, is access to our patients who have very serious
diseases and may not have opportunities until these drugs
are approved.
These are my disclosures. Myself and
Timothy Yapp are the co-moderators of this
session. These are Tim's disclosures.
I think it's the first time that somebody has more disclosures than I do.
So I'm very excited about that. My conflict of interest committee is really
stressed every time I send another
possible conflict. So,
anyway. So again, using KRAS inhibitors
as an example.
As we all know, KRAS was the undruggable
pathway for many decades, and it was really something that we
never understood.
The KRAS gene and mutations were identified quite a
few decades ago, 1982, '83-ish. One of
the challenges, I think, in drugging it was that we really didn't
understand the science, and now we understand that it's a
GTPase that cycles between the active GTP-bound
form and the inactive state, which is a
GDP-bound
form. But it's a very important pathway.
It's common in about 23% of all cancers.
And again, 40 years of trying to not only target the gene itself
or the product of the gene itself, but also downstream, has been very difficult
because there's so many different pathways downstream.
So that has not been successful either.
So I think we give Dr. Shokat's lab credit
because in
2013, he found that these cysteine residues, and this
is now just looking at the KRAS G12C
protein in the binding pocket,
was in its inactive form.
So the first KRAS G12C molecule that the FDA
approved in 2021 was sotorasib, which is an Amgen
drug. There was a second drug as well that was approved.
It was a Mirati-BMS drug, and that's the adagrasib drug.
So now we have two drugs that target that one
KRAS mutation. And what's
important is that non-small cell lung cancer is a pretty
deadly disease still, and about 36% to 41%
of patients have responded. Although one of the challenges with any targeted
therapy is duration of response.
So now we have
a lot of drugs out there.
Thanks to the first prototype, thanks to a lot of
research, both government, industry, academia.
We're in an incredible time. It's unprecedented for this
set of diseases that are KRAS driven.
And of course, Revolutions Medicine has the one that
is most advanced. And in this case, it's
basically a RAS on drug, and it's targeting
multiple KRAS mutations. And as we've
all probably seen the press release, it's met its endpoint, and we're going to hear
more about that at this meeting and at ASCO pretty
soon.
So I just wanted to set the stage here for my great panelists here who
are going to talk from different expertise point of view
that these are drugs that in metastatic
disease, pancreatic cancer, colorectal cancer, failed all other
therapies. These drugs are showing responses in phase one.
So we really are in an unprecedented time.
The last time this happened, and probably the only time I could think of was
probably with the anti-PD-1 drugs or the anti-CTLA-4 drugs.
But again, we're seeing these amazing tumor killing
responses with a decent survival rate in
previously deadly diseases. And so we wanted to
really ask the question, how much do you have to do to
develop these drugs and get them as fast as possible to patients, but
safely, and also to have accurate information?
So, also, just as I pointed out, the phase three results,
which actually when I put these slides together about two weeks ago, were not
available yet, but we're very excited because now they are available.
And actually, the endpoint that they met was even better than
we, as pancreatic cancer experts, would have expected.
So
there's no doubt they're game changers.
It's important that 90% or more of pancreatic cancer patients and
25% of colorectal cancer patients,
their cancers are dependent on this pathway.
Again, the early phase testing is showing not only a
35% overall response rate, but also there's a 90%
control rate. So these are patients who would otherwise really progress
rapidly in months, not years.
So it's really making a difference.
Right now, the other challenge is that there are over 50 different KRAS
inhibitors, and they all have a different spectrum of
inhibition and also a different spectrum of toxicities.
So it's going to overwhelm the whole
approval process not only for
industry, for people who are helping to develop these drugs in academia and
government, but also for the FDA. So we're probably going to have
even a slowing of moving the other drugs coming down the
pipeline if we don't have more of a solution.
And the most important thing is that patients with
KRAS-driven tumors are not necessarily getting
access, and those of us in the field have recognized that many of
them are dying before they ever get on a clinical trial.
There just wasn't enough clinical trials to accommodate all of the patients with
all of the stages of disease, and that's why we decided
to have this session today. So basically, the goals of this
session are we've invited these amazing panelists.
We have two clinical trialists, two people from industry,
a regulatory expert, a GI physician, a patient advocate
from the Lustgarten Foundation, and an ethicist to really just begin the
discussion. It's not the end, it's the beginning.
There's no right answer, but we really think it's important at this time with
these very active drugs, and this is just the beginning, that we
start to think about do we have the right drug development pathways or is there a
way safely with good data to accelerate?
So the three questions we're going to address is, is this primarily an access
issue, a trial design issue, or a regulatory alignment
issue?
We also are wondering where is the greatest disconnect today?
Is it science or policy or other? And then the final question
is how do we balance urgency for patients with a need for
robust evidence? I'll turn it over to Tim.
He's going to introduce our speakers.
Yeah, so thanks very much everyone for being here, and thanks, Liz, for a
fantastic introduction. So before we
hear from our speaker, who is a good friend, Dr.
Ignacio Garrido Laguna from Moffitt Cancer Center, where
he is chair of the Department of Early Therapeutics
Development. I thought we would hear from our panelists.
Let's go down the row, and if you could introduce yourself and your area
of expertise. And maybe Mark, we can start with you.
Yeah. Hi. So I'm Mark Lee. I'm CEO and co-founder
of N-Power Medicine, a medical oncologist by training, and the
focus of our company is prospective external control arms.
Hi, everybody. I'm Andy Rakeman. I'm from the Lustgarten Foundation, where I head
up the grants and research program there.
And for those of you who don't know, Lustgarten is a leading private funder of
pancreatic cancer research and really driven to transform
pancreatic cancer into a curable disease through the support of research.
Hi, I'm Mark Wickler. I'm a philosopher by training,
specialty in medical ethics.
And I'm here as both a representative of ethics, which I'm happy
is being included in this discussion,
but I'm also a participant in a clinical trial, so I can
shade light from two different perspectives.
Christian Massaccesi. I medical oncologist,
and currently, I am the CMO and the head
of development at Bristol Myers Squibb, and of course, very much involved
in this topic of today. Thank you for the invitation.
Yes. Good afternoon. I'm Lola Fashayo-Ajaye. I'm a medical oncologist.
I also have spent over a decade at the US
FDA working in regulatory science and
clinical regulatory policy. I'm currently a
consultant and a proud graduate of the Rick Pazdur
Finishing School of Regulation.
Wonderful, Lola. Thank you very much, and
thanks as well, Dr. Pazdur, for being here.
So you'll see when Liz and I put this session together, we really wanted to hear
from all of the different aspects, from a clinical,
regulatory, patient advocacy, industry, and
even from an ethical
perspective. But so before we move on to
the panel discussion, which we really want to engage with
all of you here in this room, and again, thank you all for being here.
We've asked Dr. Garrido to actually put together a
talk to not just cover the
clinical advances in terms of the
efficacy and potential toxicities that we're seeing in the clinic and clinical
trials, but also his experience with patients
firsthand. Because I can tell you as a medical
oncologist doing early phase clinical trials, we
have a ton of patients on these waiting lists, and
that is not fair on a lot of our patients.
But I think there are pros and cons of all of that, and that
is really why we're all here to have a good discussion.
So without further ado, thanks very much for being here,
Ignacio.
Well, thank you everyone. I want to start by thanking our session
chairs today for the opportunity to participate, but also for their
vision putting together this session the same week.
I guess that was by chance, but certainly good vision, right?
That we learn about the press release from that Axon
received showing truly unprecedented survival
data that as someone taking care of pancreatic cancer patients, and I think
I see many of my colleagues here in the room, we have never seen this level
of activity, certainly not this improvement in time-based
endpoints. These are my disclosures.
And I'm going to start with what I think is the most important slide of the
presentation. This is one of my patients, one of my former patients
from University of Utah who was diagnosed with
metastatic pancreatic cancer, and after progressing to a first line with
chemotherapy plus immunotherapy, he enrolled back on
November 2022 in this first human study at that time
with FMC6236. So that was
2022. He attained a complete response in
2023, so '3,
2024, 2025, 2026.
So
Those four fingers you see on my hand, it's typically the life expectancy of
a patient with metastatic pancreatic cancer, four to six months in the second
line. So he attained a complete response and continue
in complete remission, and I can tell you he's tolerating
treatment fantastically well. At the time he enrolled on the trial,
the trial was a gamble for him. He went into a low-dose level.
We didn't have much information about toxicity or
efficacy, and that highlights also the importance
of some of these early-phase trials to bring novel therapies to the
clinic. As Dr. Jaffee mentioned, drugging
RAS has been nothing close to easy.
So as you know, the first human oncogenes were
identified nearly 40 years ago by three independent group of
investigators, HRAS, and then shortly after that,
KRAS was identified in colorectal and pancreatic
cancer. It is impossible to try to summarize
the discoveries by so many brilliant investigators
and research teams, but I think that it's
of justice to highlight
the work by Kevan Shokat lab, as you heard from Dr.
Jaffee, because that opened the door to developing
sotorasib, that gained approval back in 2021, and
adagrasib, and of course, it opened the door to a number of RAS
inhibitors beyond G12C, and hopefully this year we will have an
approval for the first time for a RAS inhibitor in pancreatic
cancer.
So it is also very difficult to try to put together in a single slide
the amount of drugs that we have now in the pipeline.
And that's not really the intention of this slide.
This is not a comprehensive slide,
but it certainly summarize or have all the compounds for
which we have clinical data already in the clinic,
highlighted in green color. What you can see on the left side, it's a
class of drugs in that orange square.
These are the pan-KRAS inhibitors.
You have seen only one of them reported so far, is this molecule
from Boehringer Ingelheim, was reported at ASCO GI just a couple of
months ago. A small number of patients, 16
patients with KRAS-amplified gastroesophageal cancer, a couple of
responses, but the molecule did not have linear
pharmacokinetics and was discontinued.
As a class, all these pan-KRAS agents face a
significant challenge. They're most of them limited in their
activity to targeting the
GDP-bound form of KRAS,
which means that they will likely need to be combined with upstream inhibitors,
either EGFR or SHP2 or SOS1
inhibitors that we have already undergoing clinical
testing. In the middle of the slide, you have allele-specific
G12D inhibitors, two classes here.
QTX-3034 is the only one from which we have clinical data, but
again, limited in their activity to the GDP-bound form of
KRAS and likely will need to be combined with EGFR inhibitors or
upstream inhibitors. And then very interesting group of agents
targeting both the GDP-bound as well as the GTP-bound of
KRAS that have reported activity in the last six months,
typically with a threshold for activity around 30%.
At the bottom in this discontinued line, you have two of the products that we have
undergoing clinical testing now, including
ASP3032, which as you know,
just recently published some of the results.
And then on the right side of the screen with this red square, you have a very
interesting class of agents because they have a completely different
chemistry that gives them certainly a competitive advantage as
they don't have to struggle with using a scaffold derived
from MRTX1133, like allele-specific
G12D or pan-KRAS inhibitors. So these tricomplex
inhibitors, the three of them are already in the clinic.
A unique agent will be this molecule here, sondegrasib,
because although it's an allele-specific inhibitor, the chemistry, it's
also a tricomplex inhibitor. And then we have
a couple of allele-specific inhibitors targeting G12V, one of
them undergoing clinical testing, the other one already
discontinued.
Now,
when we look at the data, the common theme is that the response
rate with these molecules, compared to what we see with
pancreatic cancer with chemotherapy in the second-line setting, is
certainly nothing short of impressive because we're talking of response rate in the
range of 30% with disease control rates that goes from
80% to 90% across different studies.
So this is just another two molecules here, but the theme is that 30%.
And when you look at outcomes with chemotherapy, this
slide with
liposomal irinotecan and FOLFIRU, and although it's a PFS
slide, you can clearly glean from this slide that the disease control rate with
this regimen is not even close to that 80%, 90% I
was showing you, with 50% of the patients really progressing on the
first restaging CAT scan with the standard chemotherapy.
So obviously, that has generated a lot of excitement
for patients, and those of
us that are working in this field get emails constantly, both
from physicians, colleagues, but also from patients all over the
world. This is a
physician from France asking for a study for his dad.
This is an email I got from someone from Spain.
Below, one from someone from Idaho.
Just yesterday, one from Argentina asking about expanded access
programs for daraxasib-sotorasib.
So obviously, this matters to patients significantly.
This is just an anecdote because I was presented one of these clinical trials at
our scientific review committee at my former institution, and I
got this question, very right question, "Do you need another KRAS inhibitor study?"
And the answer is yes. Why? Because we have this long wait
list in every trial that you look at.
There's a clear mismatch between patient
demand for slots and the supply that we can provide on these
clinical trials. And I think that part of the discussion today needs to be about
how we can optimize the use of backfill cohorts, how we can
improve on the design of these clinical trials to help with
accelerating or expediting bringing these drugs to the
clinic. Wait list, they don't help
anyoneCertainly they don't help patients.
We cannot have wait lists with 30, 40 patients.
These patients typically need to be treated
within a couple of weeks of when we see them in the
phase one clinic. Now, wait lists don't help anyone
because they don't allow transparency, and the reason we cannot be transparent is
because in medicine we don't make decisions just based on wait lists.
We need to prioritize patients. A pancreatic cancer patient that come
to us with a liver full of mets does have
an urgency that perhaps a pancreatic cancer patient that have only one lung
lesion doesn't have. And this is hard to explain to patients because
both of them have lethal diseases.
So it's unfair to use this rank where we tell, "Well, you're second,
you're third, you're fourth." No, that's not how we make decisions in medicine.
That certainly contributes to patient frustration, too.
So something we need to think, and we prioritize some of these backfield
cohorts for patients who need to go on trial right away because they just cannot
wait. We will just lose them if they don't get a treatment that works.
Another issue is that some of these pan-KRAS
inhibitors have very limited activity against certain mutations.
I'm showing you here some data with a couple of pan-KRAS inhibitors, but I
could use you any other example. They are restricted in their
activity to targeting the GDP-bound form, and you will see because the
IC50 typically is much higher for the GTP-bound
form. So the only molecules that we have for these G12R mutations are
actually the multi-RAS inhibitors.
We don't have allele specifics against this mutation either.
Access, this is a significant problem, too.
This is a slide kindly Chris Coneran from KRAS
Kickers, a patient advocacy group that is doing fantastic group to
support help patients finding trials, sent to me, and it's a
very limited search, just for clinical trials where they look
for patients or trials that were specifically
looking for or designed for pancreatic cancer patients with direct KRAS
inhibitors. You can see a cluster of studies in the East Coast and then
this area in the Midwest Intermountain region.
But also global disparities. The European Medical
Agency recently implemented this in vitro diagnostic regulation
that effectively had a slowdown activation of
clinical trials. It was an effort to try to validate or
coordinate, improve some diagnostic text, but because of
some
limited capacity, have resulted in significant bottlenecks
in study activation in Europe. That de facto has
denied many of these European patients access to trials because
biotechs have moved to Australia, China, or US.
Now, another issue is that with all this growing
evidence, it's increasingly difficult to accept when
a patient goes to a control arm. Patients don't want to go on control arm of these
studies. They have the perception that the RAS inhibitor
is better than the standard of care.
And we have data from when the
randomized phase three study with sotorasib was conducted in lung
cancer of high withdrawal rates
shortly after the randomization, indicating patients just
go and look for other options as soon as they find that they were randomized
to the control arm, together with this early discordance,
meaning patients went off trial before
there were confirmed progression by blinded independent
central review.
Now, you heard the news, the press release about this study just this
week, right? With remarkable improvement in survival, doubling
overall survival. But I want you to look at this red square
here. These are 230 patients that never had a chance to benefit
from this drug. They contributed to the research
meaningfully. Without these patients, we wouldn't able to get this overall survival
data. But because the study did not allow for crossover, they were
never able to benefit. And the study did not allow for crossover
because we were trying to protect an endpoint, a primary endpoint of
overall survival. So there was a reason for that.
But I think with the level of evidence that is growing, we need to start
questioning if there's better ways to do this to
facilitate access to novel drugs to these patients.
And I wanted to bring this as an example to you.
This is metastatic colorectal cancer, BRAF mutant.
Life expectancy for these patients in the era prior to
BRAF inhibitors was around eight, nine months.
So as bad as pancreatic cancer, I will say.
So this is the Braywater study, where patients were randomized to control
versus chemotherapy plus a combination that
included a BRAF inhibitor, an EGFR inhibitor.
You can forget about the top arm and just focus on the
right line and the blue line. This study did not allow on the design
crossover, but because BRAF inhibitors are approved,
70% of the patients crossover, and look at the difference in survival, 30
versus 15 months. What does this mean?
This means that when you have truly a drug that it's active,
you're not going to lose your signal.
That overall survival will carry over even if patients
crossover. So that should put us at least at ease because the
signal we have seen with that multi-RAS inhibitor
is nothing short of spectacular. So I doubt that
we will lose a signal if we allow a crossover on first-line trials.
This is another example. This is completely different disease,
intrahepatic cholangiocarcinoma.
Smaller number of patients, especially also looking at patients with
IDH1 mutations, so very small bucket.
But this is a study that was designed to allow crossover.
This is a second-line trial, and the regulatory agencies
allowed PFS as a primary endpoint of the study.
They also implemented thisRank preserving structural failure
time to control for the crossover.
And although I don't have the numbers here, the difference in median survival was
10 versus six months when implementing this analysis.
So you can still capture the overall survival difference by
doing certain analysis, and there's different ways where you can also continue to
capture that survival. This is a very provocative
slide, but I wanted to show you to get thoughts for the
discussion. I put together here second-line trials in metastatic
colorectal cancer showing the survival of these studies.
As you know, in metastatic colorectal, PFS is an accepted endpoint
in the first line because it does have a good correlation with overall survival
and makes sense for a disease where the median overall survival tends to be now
above three years. But I want you to look at the Resolute data.
This is not short of these studies, different diseases.
I'm making a lot of exercise I shouldn't be doing maybe here, but I think
the figure should impact you because now we are dealing
with putting together first-line trials when we have a second-line
option that will likely be approved in the next few months that will change
forever the outcome of these patients.
And this is how
the treatment landscape is looking.
We have multiple first-line studies being developed or already
activated, combining chemotherapy plus RAS inhibitors.
And I want you to look at the control arm for these studies.
We are putting over 1,000 patients right on these
studies that are
most, to my knowledge, none of these studies are allowing crossover.
Again, because we have this primary endpoint of overall survival that
we have come to agree, and I think we need to start discussions to
question that. And I want also to think about how we can design these
studies better. These studies on the left side, they come all from the same
company. They're going to do three different randomized phase three
studies with three different control arms.
So can we be a little bit more bold? Are we
willing to take a risk? Are we willing to do platform studies where we have a
running control arm, and then we implement all these
experimental arms to compare against that running control arm?
Certainly, multiple caveats with this. Patients are not enrolling at the same time.
Your experimental arm may enroll
patients at a different time to the control arm, and that creates some
nuances. Digital twins.
It's perhaps a little bit early to imagine that, right?
I didn't mention on the prior slide, to my knowledge, we don't have a
platform trial yet that have led to a regulatory approval.
So certainly, I will see concerns on the pharmaceutical side with
that approach. Similar with digital twins, but we have now technology.
This is a study from France where they developed this Icella version two platform,
where they took advantage of deep understanding of mechanisms
of disease, resistance, pathway inhibition, as well as PK,
and came up with these digital twins and then did this in silico
clinical trial where they essentially attained the same
results compared to a retrospective studies
comparing two different EGFR inhibitors.
Synthetic control arms, they have already been used for dose optimization.
This is with cetuximab. They allow to
change the label from a Q week or weekly to a Q two week.
Although they have not provided definitive data to
support approval of single agent arm, they definitely are
used for context, right? To provide supporting evidence,
like it was done with the MEK inhibitor in pediatric patients with
neurofibroma. And I want to bring to your attention this example with
endometrial KRAS G12D mutant. So we recently
reported last year with QTX-3034, a
G12D off inhibitor, a small cohort
of patients, but with a nice signal with endometrial and G12D.
These patients are not easy to find.
When you're trying to span this in a clinical trial, you struggle to identify
these patients. These are 60,000 patients, 20% of them have a KRAS
mutation, 20% of those will be KRAS G12D.
So can we design studies with a single arm
to get response rate and then compare to an external
control arm, a synthetic arm, to try to get approval in that setting
for very
niche scenarios?
Project Orbis, this is, I think, a fantastic project launched
by the FDA. I'm sure Lola will comment more on this, right?
But it has allowed to coordinate
in parallel review submissions, and we have already data that this
decreased the submission gap as well as the time that it
takes to review the drugs. This is data looking at the Swiss
regulatory agency.
Expanded access, this is a hot topic.
I mentioned that we have patients reaching out asking for this, right?
And there's multiple nuances with expanded access programs.
So we need to think about safety.
Some of these drugs, we're still early.
We're still trying to learn about signals of toxicity.
A few weeks ago, you learn about a program potentially being
halted because of a case of pneumonitis, right?
As we expand, as these patients are treated by hundreds of
thousands, we may see toxicity we haven't seen.
Expanded access program have a problem, is that you miss the data in
half of this, like shown with the German and the Italian expanded access program
with G12C inhibitors, and that mean that you might not be collecting relevant
toxicities from these studies. There's also the potential
impact on clinical trials. If you allow an expanded access program, then your
patients are effectively crossover to that drug.
I think in my opinion, the best way to do this is to allow crossover within the
study where you keep direct or tight control of what's happening with these
patients. And then, of course, operational constraints.
So companies may or not have the resources to run in parallel
expanded access program together with the clinical trials.
They may compromise some of the resources they need to get the clinical trial done
and complete and get this drug to get an approval.
But also for the study sites. Expanded access
programs require also resources from the clinical trials
office and human resources that some sites may not have.
Master protocols. This is just an example with sotorasib, where you see
the use of multiple arms running in parallel with
intention to identify a signal that you can then expand in a
seamless way to phase three, like happened in colorectal with
sotorasib in combination with panitumumab already approved,
and now in combination with chemotherapy in the first line.
And then adaptive designs, like often in oncology, clinical trials
are just too rigid, drug centric, and we need to
move from that approach to a prismatic strategy as
very beautifully delineated in this paper, where we use
each of the trials as an engine for discovery, taking all the
multidimensional knowledge we acquire, both from the patient but also from
real-world data, taking advantage of artificial intelligence and
machine learning toThen also
be able to synthesize data from
multiple institutions, massive amount of data without
compromising security of the data or
confidentiality. And then, of course, we need to think about
mechanisms of resistance. We have now the technology to understand some of the
mechanisms of resistance we have through ctDNA, but remember,
ctDNA will only provide information about
mutations. We still miss the mechanisms of resistance for
half of the patients. So we will need other omics platforms like RNA
sequencing, biopsies on tissue to understand these
mechanisms of resistance and be able to build on combinations, because
it is very clear now that for pancreas, RAS inhibitors are going to be
the backbone for the treatment of the future.
ctDNA applications, I mentioned
some of them already, right? And I think that I'm going
to leave you with a design where we can use ctDNA
as part of adaptive combination trials.
For instance, imagine we're combining a Pan-KRAS inhibitor
and allele-specific inhibitor targeting G12D.
We can collect ctDNA samples. Let's say we see emergence
of a KRAS amplification as a mechanism of resistance, and during a
dose-escalation study, we can hypothesize we may need to increase the
dose of the Pan-KRAS degrader to overcome
resistance. And I'm going to leave it here.
This is the summary of what I just went through.
I'm not going to go through the slide again.
I'm going to just leave it there as points for discussions.
Looking forward to the panel discussion.
Thanks very much, Ignacio. So,
we have about an hour, 55 minutes to really
get through this.
And we really want to involve everyone in the audience, so please feel free to
approach any of the mics
over there. But maybe I can start, and
I'll open with maybe a controversial
question, but one that you actually posed, Ignacio.
So do we need another KRAS inhibitor?
And obviously, there are different types of KRAS inhibitors,
allele-specific and maybe more multi-specific in KRAS
inhibitors, but do we need another me-too drug?
Because I don't personally think that that's the answer
to covering our patients right now as we
have this huge backlog of slots, right?
I think ultimately we all want to try and get these drugs through and
approved if they are genuinely good drugs.
So what do you guys think about
this issue? Do we need another KRAS inhibitor?
Maybe Christian, you want to take this?
Thank you.
I think, Tim, the answer is definitely yes.
We are just at the beginning, and
we have seen with the 12 C that the next
generation drugs can be even better
because they are simply better engineered.
I think we
have now data with the Pan-RAS, but we don't know what the Pan-KRAS
can deliver. And let's not forget that the data that we have with the
Pan-RAS are in second-line and third-line,
and then we need to understand the combinability that eventually you need
in frontline, and maybe
a Pan-KRAS can have a different profile. We don't know.
The allele specifics, also we are the beginning.
We have seen the data with the covalent and non-covalent inhibitors.
We are now start to see how the product eventually can
play. We need to learn a lot there, and there are alleles that we
didn't even target. B, for instance, is one of them.
So I think definitely we're just the beginning.
It's very exciting, but we are the beginning, so we need definitely more data.
We need more clinical research.
So I think we all agree we need better drugs, and so we need
more drugs, but better drugs that actually
are a stepwise improvement on whatever's out there.
But do we need another me-too drug, I guess is the question I'm asking,
right? If it's not differentiated
pre-clinically from whatever's
already in a clinical trial and perhaps three or four years behind,
do we really need another me-too drug? I guess that's my question.
As a personal
viewpoint and company viewpoint, I'm not going to develop a me-too drugs.
In the moment I know it's a me-too drug, I'm not going to develop it.
I need to understand sometimes the pre-clinical package is not enough to
tell you how differentiated they can be.
Yeah.
So you need maybe to be into patients-
Right
... to get some-
Of course, not everyone's BMS, and not everyone has the might of
your pre-clinical machinery. So I guess a lot of biotech
companies out there, not just in the US, but perhaps in other
countries,
who actually are generating a lot of me-too drugs to really
jump on the whole bandwagon effect.
And that's really my concern there, that we're going to end up with a lot
of drugs and really neglect perhaps
other areas of oncology that perhaps we should be thinking about as well.
But what do you think, Ignacio?
Yeah.
I tend to agree with Christian. I think that it's perhaps a little bit
too early to talk about me-too drugs.
The way I look at that is when we have an approval, right, then of course.
We may have an approval this year. I show a couple of molecules there
on the right side, multi RAS inhibitors.
I can tell you the pre-clinical data I have seenWith the Erasca
molecule, looks like it's perhaps a better molecule than the
first in class.
They have reported responses at a much lower dose level,
not disclosed at conferences, but disclosed publicly, eight milligrams
versus a higher dose level for Revolution
Medicine. They may also have less toxicity. Why?
Because maybe it's a more potent molecule, but by being more potent,
it might be active at lower dose levels that perhaps are not hitting some
of the RAS alleles that the multi-RAS inhibitor is
hitting. So I agree with Kristen. We need more RAS inhibitors.
We need better molecules, not me-too.
From an ethical perspective, I might maybe suggest
rephrasing the question to, are there good
reasons to do this
research?
And if there are, then are there overriding
reasons for giving priority to other
areas of research? So that's the way I would think about it.
There may be very good reasons, but one has to consider the big
picture, how that fits in, and whether priority should
go here or somewhere else.
Lola, can you weigh in, being someone who's dealt with the regulatory component of
it?
Yeah. I think that for small molecule
inhibitors, we certainly have seen a lot of
disparate safety efficacy profiles, even when the target is the
same. And so I think in the space of KRAS,
pan-KRAS,
we are still early enough that I
don't think it's
premature to ask the question. I think it's an appropriate question.
I think for PD-1 inhibitors, we saw really a lot of
consistency across many products.
And so, the question there was an appropriate one in that,
do we need more PD-1 inhibitors
for the sake of convenience? So not having to purchase it to do
studies. But I think in this case, I think it's appropriate so long as
there's a justifiable reason
to do that,
including improving the safety profile,
improving the efficacy profile.
I think it's appropriate.
And can I just ask, if you get the first drug
past the finishing line,
I presume that helps all of the subsequent drugs if they have similar
profiles, I presume. Maybe you can talk through
the considerations there from a regulatory perspective.
Well, I think, the first to the party, so to
speak, has both a higher
bar, in terms of the scrutiny paid upon it,
especially if it's a novel therapy with very distinct safety
profile. There's a lot of scrutiny on evaluating that benefit risk
for that product.
I think if you're second to the party, I think the
bar may be higher because there's already something approved that
patients
can use.
When there is really strong efficacy data,
some of the things that we worry about, heterogeneity of the patient
population, the endpoints,
those take a backseat, a secondary seat to
really strong efficacious drug. I think we run into
problems when you have to squint, stand on one foot,
and hold your hand up to see the clinical benefit, and that's where some
of the
challenges we have in really discerning, is this effect
due to the drug? Or is it a patient selection issue?
Are there other issues to consider here?
If I could, I was just going to rephrase the question
in another dimension, which is, what happens to all the control arms for
the trials that are happening right now for the follow-on molecules?
And I think maybe we can agree that
we have to plan for this rapidly evolving landscape and the
standard of care as these molecules demonstrate their activity and get
approved.
Yeah.
You're not going to be able to enroll those control arms
anymore with
molecules with this kind of activity out there.
And so how do we anticipate that rapidly evolving
state,
and avoid the situation where patients will not accept randomization -
Yeah
... to a regimen they know is inferior?
Yeah. I think that's a great point, and I think at FDA, we
had actually, and I will say this because this is publicly available
information, but we worked very closely with the Cholangiocarcinoma
Foundation and sponsors who are developing drugs for that disease
to really have a trial, a platform trial with a common control
arm to support all of the drugs that were being developed
in that disease in a molecular subset.
And really the biggest challenge there was just getting all of the
companies to agree to this single trial where even though
their drugs weren't going to be compared to each other, they were going to be
compared to a common control. There's still the optics of having
your drug right next to another drug in the same trial,
and those that had obviously higher response rates did
not have as much concern. They were happy.
But those where the effects weren't that big or where there was safety
issues, they were concerned. So the biggest issues were really hurdles, were
really more business
issues rather than regulatory acceptance of that
approach. Because I agree, we can see that these are all in development, and we can
plan for it.
But wouldn't the argument there be that if the drug is inferior
You know, against another drug of the same pathway or
class, it's going to show inferiority anyway, so
learn it faster.
Well, I think that's a question of who gets to decide that, right?
It's not the regulatory agency's decision whether a
drug gets developed, right? It's those who are running the
trials who get to decide, "Do I open this trial in my site?" And so
I think that that's where a
discussion needs to occur.
Right.
Can we move to the question, I think this is why this
session really started. What is the best way to balance
patient urgency with the need for the most
robust data? And maybe Andy, you could talk a little bit
first about your side of things
or perspective .
Oh, no, thanks, Liz. And I think that that is important, and it's something that
the other clinicians here have mentioned this about the questions they get
constantly from patients really looking to get on these arms.
We get it all the time at the foundation.
And I think there is that sense of urgency among patients of really wanting to be
able to do something different here
and be able to move things quickly.
And I think particularly from the point of view of the foundation where we have
that dual role of really being a patient-driven foundation that's trying to address
the needs out there, but one that's doing that through research of wanting to
maintain that high quality of research going forward.
And I think that it really is the key question for us, and it's something we've
been starting to have a lot of discussions around. How do we bring together?
Are there collaborative platform approaches?
Are there ways of engaging across that are going to help us to move
forward on these faster and better in a way that gives the most patients possible
the best access to these drugs? And I think it's a problem
that I imagine is going to continue to
grow as we go forward. We hear talk about the
data release this week from RedMed, unprecedented,
spectacular, exceptional. We hear all these things,
but it's also still not enough is another way to look at it, right?
So we know that these drugs are going to be part of a
solution for pancreas cancer, but they're not going to be the solution for pancreas
cancers. I think we also have to look forward to the world of how do we not only
get drugs through an approval process as monotherapies, but are we
setting up in an appropriate way that we're going to
be able to run the studies and do the research that's going to help us identify the
right combinations to use them in, the right patients to use them in, the right
sequencing,
all of those things together that I think now is the time as a
community where we really have the ability if we can come together on
that to do things differently to really accelerate that timeframe moving
forward by planning for success at this point.
That's great.
I see several
pancreatic cancer, famous pancreatic
physicians in the audience, and we're very curious
as to your thoughts on what you're seeing yourself in the
clinic in terms of patients who are on
these very long wait lists and limited trial slots,
and how that actually impacts your patient care decisions, your
thoughts as to
endpoints on frontline studies, randomized control
arms.
So please feel free to
go to the mics or
anyone else, please feel free to chime in as well.
In the meantime, Mark, I wonder if maybe you can tell us a little bit more about
the
living
synthetic control arms that you've kind of mentioned in
brief.
Yeah. No, I think the concept of an external control arm has been
around a long time, and proposed conceptually as
a very powerful way to
limit or perhaps augment the internal
control within a randomized design.
I think there's always been this thought that maybe someday you could eliminate it
altogether, but I think let's just start with something a little bit more
reasonable.
We've actually, in reality, had relatively limited success with
external control arms
outside of niche indications, pediatrics or very rare
disease, where randomization is extremely challenging
or even impossible. But the real win here will
be in indications that are much more common
and as a way to avoid some of these challenges that we're describing
today.
The limitation has largely come from retrospective
approaches to building these ECAs where we go back
into old registry data. Sometimes it's old trial
data. Very often, in the last 10 years, it's been about real-world
data, stuff that we scrape out of the EHRs.
And no surprise, oncology is very complicated.
Mm-hmm.
And clinical trial data looks very different from
real-world data. And so while there's been a tremendous
investment and effort into massaging that
data and retrofitting it to looking like trial data, I think we can
safely conclude it's extremely challenging, if not impossible.
And so what we've proposed at Empower in the last five
years is to create a system where you generate these
prospectively, by design, under protocol, and just
anticipating what the control arms are going to be, what
pharma is going to need,
and then to just build them out in the standard of care patients
that are actually the majority of patients out there.
And actually, one other point to make is that on the map, you
could see that the vast majority of the US does
not have access to these K-RAS trials, right?
I think something like 70% to 80% of patients don't live within
two hours of one of these trial centers.
Those are patients getting standard of careThey represent the
actual population. That's a ripe
population in which to develop these control arms prospectively and
by design.
So I'll throw that out there.
Dr. Pazdur?
I guess the elephant in the room is: do you need a randomized study?
Okay. And I think that's the question that we should be asking here,
because the primary issue of a randomized study, one of the
things that is inherent in this is the issue
of equipoise. And when you have
discrepant efficacy that comes out very early on, do
you need a randomized study? And is this
the ideal situation of basically looking at an
external control? We are not approving a placebo here,
obviously. This is obviously a big breakthrough
therapy. So when you have unprecedented response rates,
I think that this is a perfect example of where you may
want to move the drug up as quickly as possible in a
frontline setting and compare it to an external control.
Because what patient is really going to be wanting to be randomized
to a 5-FU containing combination regimen, right?
Okay. And when you do have a big effect,
okay,
that gives you more confidence in using an external control here.
And I think that that's a major issue.
Having had this experience, and I know Liz has had this experience also in the
development of the BRAF drugs for melanoma,
did we need randomized studies necessarily there, okay?
And especially when one was comparing it to DTIC, for example.
Yes, we were able to show a survival advantage, but
so what? Okay. And here again, there's a general principle here that
I think we have to enunciate, and that is the clinical trials are
here to serve the patients, and the patients are not here to serve the clinical
trials, right? And here again, I think that this is a
principle. Do you have equipoise?
And if you don't have equipoise, why are we doing the randomized trial?
And there's plenty examples of this when you do have major
breakthroughs such as this. So I think that's a fundamental question that should be
addressed here. And when you don't have equipoise,
that's going to lead to potentially erroneous results.
As far as having multiple of the same drugs,
we could learn from the PD-1 experience. We don't need 10 of them.
Okay? Or how many are there now? 14? I don't know.
12.
Probably even more. But we do need multiple, and let me tell you why.
Multiple drugs with different sponsors lead to rapid
development of multiple indications.
And remember, we saw with the PD-1 drugs over a five-year period of
time,
remarkable breakthroughs looking at these drugs in
multiple, multiple indications relatively quickly, and it pushed the
field dramatically. No one sponsor could have possibly done that
all by themselves. There's also questions of drug
shortages that may ensue, that one needs more than
one drug on the market. The ability really to move the field
forward, I think, is important. But one doesn't need 15 of the same drugs,
okay. I think we overdid it then. In fact, we wrote the paper, if people remember.
It was called "The Wild West of PD-1 Drug Development" in "The New England Journal
of Medicine." And it pointed out the positive issues of multiple drugs,
but also the negative issues. And I think there's always a balance there.
But I really think the elephant in this room is really, do you need a
randomized study? So I'd love to hear Lola's opinion on that.
Yeah.
Since she is a graduate.
No, I mean, I-
Give us right answer.
No, no. I mean, I agree with you. I think there's also lots of precedent at
FDA
approvals with really unprecedented results in
settings where there's really no effective therapies, where the approvals were
based on single arm trials.
Even in a curative intent setting where FDA has agreed,
for ducilimab to a single-arm trial after discussion with the
community around the reasons why that was okay.
So there's not a one size fits all approach.
I think a lot of it has to do really with how strong is your evidence,
how reliable is that preliminary evidence,
in really being able to anchor assumptions about how this will
do when you enroll many more patients that are not as
carefully selected. So in this situation, we're talking about a highly
effective therapy, you don't have to squint to see the treatment
effect. But many times you do have to do that, and then you have a lot
of proposals around more innovative
approaches, but when you don't have large treatment effects,
these other factors around sort of how contemporaneous are the
data, what is the standard of care at the time, were that
retrospective external control cohort
data was collected. Those things start to really impact
the clinical outcomes or at least make it very challenging to discern,
do you actually have a treatment effect here?
If I could just mention one other thing, Lola.
One of the things that we have to realize is that these trials were done in
refractory disease second-line patients.
Drugs only get better when they're moved up to an earlier disease
setting. And we had this thing, if you remember it, we called it reverse
accelerated approvals.
Yeah.
Okay. Where-
Project Frontrunner.
And Project Frontrunner, which is kind of similar,
where you have had a already established survival
advantage with this drug. Okay. So you could leverage that data,
basically, and looking at,
for example, a single arm trial, and also bolstering that with
an external control, because one would expect to have a bigger effect
here. So I think that's really important, and it goes-The concept, I think
is also, as Lola mentioned, the agency's interest, and I
can't speak for the agency now because I don't work there.
Neither of us do, unfortunately. But that's another
story, that we could really
leverage that information and getting it out as quickly as possible.
Because here again, I think there is a tremendous need for this drug.
And the best way of addressing a need for a
drug is to have an approved drug. And these drugs will not be hard to
manufacture as such. I don't think there's manufacturing issues with these small
molecules, but this should be rapidly addressed,
really, from patients' needs.
I would like to put this, what Dr. Pazdur and Lola put in the
context of the big picture. Oncology is becoming a
constellation of rare diseases. This is the reality.
Because the science give us more and more precise
subgroups, targets, and engineering is
very sophisticated. So we have better drug, more selective, more potent.
The problem is we are
dealing with rare diseases, and we need to
be able to work as an ecosystem in this
context. And randomized trials sometimes can
kill the effort of developing this kind of...
Because it's not any more the science, the bottleneck.
The bottleneck now is the development part.
And that in rare indications,
for a company, the most important thing is the cycle time
and how fast you can bring the drug to the patients,
especially if you believe the drug can bring benefit to the patients.
If we are not making this faster, and I really like what Mark is
bringing forward because I'm very willing to find a compromise.
That is, it can be synthetic control arm prospectively acquired as a first step,
but this is really needed. Otherwise, we will have a bottleneck in the development
and we will need to, unfortunately, stop to develop some very
promising drugs.
There's randomization and there's randomization.
Obviously, FDA has approved drugs on
small randomized trials, less than 170
patients. And those trials really address
issues around the heterogeneity of a patient population where we may
not really have a good understanding of how does this group of
patients fare with standard of therapy in a way that's
measurable and measurably described, right?
And we've had approvals based on single arm trials with just as
large number of patients, 174 patients as an
example. So I think the issue isn't really the randomization.
The issue is what is the question you're trying to address, and how do you get
the best data to describe and measure the
effect of the treatment? And that could vary.
It could be that you need randomization to be able to evaluate survival because you
think survival is the better measure of the drug's efficacy because you have
0% response rates, right? Whereas single arm trial is not going to be
helpful. And in some cases, a single arm trial is just
enough. If you're getting response rates of 90%, complete response rates
of 78%, do you really need to be
randomizing patients to something that you know is going to be a lower
response rate? And that goes to the issue of equipoise.
So it's a very
situation and context specific issue.
If I could just add one more comment here.
There's the equipoise on the part of the investigator.
But what we're seeing with what Ignacio described with this
asymmetric dropout,
participants having their own perspective on
the value of
even an experimental agent in this case, where they probably had some
inkling that there was activity,
that
actually should be very concerning for investigators and
for drug developers, because even with
randomization, how do you interpret a study where you
lose,
probably selectively in a skewed way, control patients?
How will that study actually be interpreted at the end of the day?
Mark, can you give the ethical point of view?
Well, I think that's... And I'm glad this is being
included in... Oh, you were talking to me.
Yeah, you, Mark.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Mark Douglas.
Okay. All right.
Two Marks.
Yeah.
I'm sure that's one of the reasons I was invited here, and I have to say,
I'm just extremely pleased that that is being included
in this session.
Unfortunately, I view my role as an
ethicist, not so much to be a philosopher king who
gives you the right answer, but as somebody who
guides in the thinking process
and tries to assure that the
relevant values, interests, and
goals are all considered and given
their due consideration.
It's maybe an
unfortunate fact, or maybe it's not unfortunate that
there
are a wide range of different values and
interests
in our society generally and on these issues.
So to me, the main thing is to
identify the issues and the... I'm sorry, the goals, the
values, the interests,
and be sure that one has done a
due consideration of all of them. And then I
think the answer is in discussions like
this,
where having put all that's relevant onto the
tableThen there is an informed,
reasonable discussion of them, and I don't think it's
overly optimistic to say that when you've got
it down to that level,
reasonable people might very well be able to come to
some agreement. What I can do,
in addition to that general statement, is to say
that I think that even though I would agree that there
is an ethical imperative
to hasten the approval of drugs
and eliminate unnecessary and unwarranted
obstacles.
The problem is that what is unnecessary,
what is unwarranted, is in part
value-laden, and so it's not just clearly clinical or
scientific, and that's where what I said about values
comes into play.
Just to add, there are some
kind of hazards in the process that one should be
aware of, and I'll just name a few of them.
One is what's called the therapeutic misconception,
which may be in
play
with the long waiting lists to get into clinical trials,
where patients can think of these clinical trials
as therapy rather than as clinical trials.
And I should add that in my experience, sometimes
the patient's so-called therapeutic
misconception
can be aided by an investigator
therapeutic mispresentation. And it's very, I
think, important to make sure that
patients are aware that, yeah, there are really best-case
scenarios, and that's what everybody hopes for, but there are also
worst-case scenarios, and people should be aware of that
when they
decide to go into a clinical trial.
And then the only other hazard that I'll mention now is
what's called the rule of rescue,
which is humans, maybe fortunately,
tend to respond very sympathetically to
identifiable individuals. So in the
clinic, a clinical patient.
Broader public, if a little child falls down a mine shaft,
it doesn't matter how many million dollars it will take to rescue
them. But when we hear statistics like there are a
million people in Sudan who are starving to death,
eh, that's life.
Or if we hear statistics, not we, I mean, not people in this
audience, but the broader public, statistics about
deaths from certain diseases, it could be the same reaction as
opposed to someone they know or somebody they
care about.
So just to mention a few obstacles along the way that
people should be aware of.
Thanks very much, Mark.
Teri, do you want to provide your perspective? I'm sure.
Yeah. Hi. Thanks for having me. I'm Teri Conneran with KRAS Kickers, and
the bulk of what we do is we work with patients where they are right now.
We're not funding research and policy.
And from that end, we're more community focused.
And so the question and highlight I'd like to bring to everybody's
attention is that
first of all, let me point out that we had to submit a
second separate group just for people that were on these
drugs because it was getting so
snarky in our Facebook forums and stuff that people were
very
mean. Okay. They were just mean. Okay. It was like middle school all over again.
"How'd you get into this? How'd you get that?" This waiting list thing is for
real, but I would like to encourage everybody in this room, wherever it
is, and whatever it is you're standing to do, this is an amazing
opportunity for people to stand back, just the average
patient, stand back and have an opportunity to see something
that went through a pipeline that works.
And take a look at clinical trials at a time that we're all very
suspicious about what's happening across all channels.
And so I think that even though right now it's like everybody's celebrating this,
and it's fantastic to see the improvements of
survival and what have you, it's nowhere near enough.
And where it is right now in pancreatic cancer is going to move forward to what it
was like in lung cancer, say, 20 years ago, and there's still
huge divides and problems as far as being able to find trials,
understand trials, biomarker testing at its most
basic level, and I believe there was a study that something
ridiculous... Sorry, I'm not a statistics person.
A ridiculous number of doctors did not understand the percentage of
patients with PDAC that had K-RAS mutations,
and that's inexcusable at this point.
And so I want to just encourage this amazing opportunity for this to happen,
to move forward with this momentum, and so anything that we can
do to escalate it, and at the same time,
the side effects from these drugs are not easy.
They're really, really hard. And so is there more
necessary? There's better necessary.
Thanks so much, Teri. That's a great
perspective. Bob, did you want to go?
Oh, hi. Bob Vonderheide. I'm at Penn.
Great discussion, and I get those emails
too. We all do. So frustrating. Patients are on waiting
lists, or they're randomized and...
But
we're excited by the data
Because it was a randomized study.
And in pancreas cancer, how many have we taken to Phase
3 where the randomized study was disappointing?
So, it's a little bit like, now we know it works,
but we didn't know before. I think
the thing that frustrates me more is that the rate of time, the
number of patients who can go on study is we haven't talked
about changing that.
And so patients build up, and they sit around and wait and pass away.
So
now the dam has burst.
I see all sorts of companies here. You all have these drugs.
We now know the answer.
How are we going to prevent Rick's Wild West?
Everyone's sitting here thinking, "I'm going to get my approval."
But the patients want to know how they're going to get access.
What is a solution this panel might have for a
cooperative approach that I think AACR
leadership would be really interested in?
I'm sure Lustgarten leadership would be interested in.
NCI will be interested in this. As a national effort
to harmonize the
testing and approval of these drugs much faster than what's going to
happen if we don't.
Great point.
Do you guys want to chime in? Andrew?
I can start. I don't know if I have a solution to say other than to say
I completely agree, Bob, with that, and that is something that we're starting to
talk about and talk about with Louis too, about how do we really get together.
And I think you're right. It is going to take the companies working
with
foundations and patient groups, working with professional organizations like AACR,
working with the larger government funders, working with the regulators to try
to map this out going forward. Which it's not
complex, but it's not easy. Or it's a simple idea, but
a thing that'll take time to get there.
And that's what I was alluding to earlier when I made the comment.
I think now is the opportunity to
see the real benefit of these drugs or the real potential for the benefit of these
drugs long term. That's the part where we can compress
that timeline today by really working to make sure that that
coordination and communication is happening now or is getting set up now.
I think the first approvals are going to come.
These things are going to roll, where eventually we'll get to a place where these
drugs
are working well in patients, and we're learning about them.
But I think that
last yard, we can get to that point faster
by working together. And I think we've started to look at
the...
Fortunately, I think the pancreas community has been very collaborative.
We've seen successful building out of large clinical trial efforts and
things moving forward. And I think what's different now is we're going to have
drugs that look exciting to test in those
kind of models.
That really lets us put the rubber to the road, so to
speak.
Thanks, Andrew. Lola?
Yeah, I think we really have to be provocative
here and challenge what we've accepted
so far in terms of
how do we know what trials are available, and how do we know the
real status of those trials, and how can that information be
accessible to every single patient,
and to every single treating physician.
We do not have that, and that is a problem.
We have pockets of it. We have PanCAN, we have
your groups, and other patient groups that are
attempting to build these databases of clinical trials.
But that doesn't give real-time information as to what
is the status of this trial at this location that's close to this patient.
So we really need a fundamental system that
really changes the approach to access to
information about clinical trials in the US.
It's interesting that you mentioned foundations and
universities. Most of the data is sitting in companies, and we really don't get
access. And again, I realize, I understand
why that data is kept under
wraps, but I also don't because we want to help patients.
And I'm not sure what the solution is, but I do want to raise that
point that it really isn't going to take just
academics, government, and
foundations. We really need everybody in the community, which is all the people,
all of the companies that are developing these drugs.
The one other question that I think this is a great discussion
that I'm wondering about, and again, I know this is hard financially,
but now that we have a drug that's showing this activity, but it's also
showing toxicities, and someone online has said the picture
of
the prior congressperson really is scary.
Those lesions on his skin, that's
real with these drugs.
How many companies should be developing down the first generation,
or is it a time to pivot and try to
make these drugs more targeted, more safe,
less toxicities? I don't know. I know it's an important question, but
I also know that a lot of these drugs are already in Phase 1 or heading
toward Phase 1.
It's a free market system, end of discussion, and we dealt
with this with the PD1 drugs.
You can't tell somebody they can't develop a drug.
But I think this also offers us an opportunity to compare these
drugs relatively quickly, and there will be better
safety profiles which will encourage better drug
development. But I think the major thing is really how to
move these drugs to compare themselves to each other so everybody gets
the same class of drugs here. So
there's equipoise, at least in a randomized study.
You could do this through non-inferiority trials, which are large
trials, but this is a common disease.
The other thing, point I want to mention, we're talking about this just
everybody here pretty much is from the US, okay?
But there is an international community also, and international drug
developers and regulatory agencies that need to be harmonized on
this also. But it's really going to be difficult to say you can't
develop a drug, okay? That's certainly not in the purview of the
FDA or any government agency that I
know.
And remember also, one would think as we had with the PD-1
drugs, the wish
that the fact that we would have a large number of
drugs would reduce the price of these drugs.
Yeah.
So I think maybe we're in a new world here, and maybe we
could have multiple drugs out there, and maybe that would reduce the
price
because that's becoming more and more of an issue, obviously.
That's great points.
Do you want to go ahead?
Hi. Thank you. Woong-Ki Park from Memorial Sloan Kettering.
Yeah, just to highlight, I'm just waiting for my turn.
I'm getting a Facebook message from Peru asking for, "I'm a
physician of so-and-so, and I need an access to your trial XYZ."
It's really heartbreaking, and it's very
difficult.
Exciting, but at the same time, I see the other darker side,
too. As a practical matter,
it's slightly off the topic, but I saw the slide from Ignacio.
I think it's really important to rethink the endpoints, too.
And major molecular response is real.
And when you see that, that's going to really extend a lot.
And I know it's early, but I would like to hear from FDA,
do you have any task force or any white paper, anything that you would like
to continue to evaluate this as a new endpoint to speed
up the readout and development?
I'm hearing that maybe a randomized trial is not what we really
want to do, but it's important, but getting those surrogate markers and
understanding the efficacies and, once you standardize it, these are
numbers, and it's very accurate. So I think you can actually use it.
So
yeah, maybe we have a lot of investigators here, so maybe appetite for a task
force, maybe.
Yeah. I presume you're talking about ctDNA,
essentially. And absolutely, I think there's a lot of interest there.
I think myeloma probably is leading the way.
There was actually an FDA ACR
workshop specifically on endpoints that Lillian
Siu and a few others had organized.
So I would certainly urge you to have a look at that particular workshop
because those exact points were specifically discussed,
and Dr. Pazdur was there as well.
And here again, I think that circulating DNA would give us greater credibility,
but we do have response rates even now that are quite impressive here.
Absolutely.
So I think that just adds to the data and gives
us more confidence. Maybe it will predict
earlier
analysis of response by using these other markers
or earlier detection of the response.
But we do have this here now, so it's not like we're trying to
reinvent it.
Absolutely right. This is not a gray zone. We know this works.
And to be honest, we've known this for some time because investigators
in Phase I, and there are several of you here in the audience, we
know when we're dealing with a good drug because we
see it in front of us. We see patients respond.
We see the scans
with fantastic shrinkage of cancers.
It really is striking. But obviously, again, we
have to be sensible about it and be measured, but I
think this is a great opportunity to really push the bar.
But certainly for the gray zone, I really think that's where ctDNA can
really come in to support the totality of data that
perhaps one brings to the FDA.
One of the other things, because we're talking about a great pressure from
patients on this, is the use of expanded access data.
And we have specifically stated that that can be used in a
dossier to support and augment a
dossier for approval of a drug. So one from the
companies that are doing randomized studies or are developing a
regulatory single-arm trial to be compared to external data,
if that is where this field goes to.
Think about using, in addition to that expanded access
data. Here again, it's not going to be single-patient access, it's going to be
probably a
access
study, basically, a large trial. But that data can also be
used to augment the approval of the drug, too.
So really, I think we really have to be cognizant of the fact that we really have
to get this drug or these types of drugs to people as rapidly as
possible. It's not really in anybody's best interest to
just say we're going to be focusing on drug development as we
have always done. But the expanded access program is
an area that can
avail drugs to a large population,
and that data can be used, and that data can be
simplified for regulatory submission.
Obviously, we're interested in response rates there and only to collect
the X-rays on responders, for example.
We rarely see non-responders being
misread, so to speak. So, this could simplify things as
far as the cost of really submitting even expanded access data
to the agency.
And just to be clear, data
from expanded access, either protocols or
single-patient access, is already being used in
many FDA approvals.
Most commonly as part of the overall safety database
for the product. So I just want to be clear there that a lot
of these issues have already-- There's precedent for them.
But there are ways to sort of prospectively, particularly when you have
patients in long lines waiting to access the therapy, there's
ways to be prospectively collecting information that could be
useful to support efficacy.
A very loose eligibility criteria for these, including patients that have
never received treatment and patients that have received treatment,
differences in renal function, et cetera.
Yeah, that's a good point. Yeah.
Yeah. I just wanted to make perhaps a bit of a provocative comment, because I
think we're framing this as a bit of a challenge that's
posed to us now by the advent of these very
exciting drugs and perhaps thinking about how to
accommodate the setting where you have
molecules with unprecedented activity.
But this is an opportunity for us to just reflect on some of the
slides Ignasio put up.
He's just showing two drug companies in this space, and you better
believe there's going to be a whole much more that will pile in.
And the designs of their programs are essentially the same.
A thousand patients going on control arms.
And that's going to be, multiply that by 10 going forward.
And with patients taking such an active role in
shaping how we're designing these programs and
voting with their feet,
perhaps even walking out of some of these studies.
This is an opportunity for us to challenge the basic paradigm.
And I love the idea of the platform study.
Why aren't we thinking about this as a community, as a
portfolio that we're prosecuting, and not just a collection of
individual research projects?
There was a comment online before. Right. Give me a minute.
One thing missing so far from the discussion is the financial reality of
running clinical trials. Developers would like to access as many patients
at as many sites as possible, but it just isn't financially
possible.
So I don't know if anyone has a response to that or not.
The
development cost of a drug
in oncology across the age, it depends, is between $700
million to $2 billion
from first into human to approval.
And then you need to take in consideration also the cost of the failed
drug,
because this is the drug that succeed.
Of course, some drug, the attrition is higher at the beginning of the journey and
the cost are less. So the costs are very important.
This is why. And they are even more relevant in a
moment in which you are in a smaller indication.
Pancreatic cancer is not a small indication, but
G12D in pancreatic cancer is a
small indication.
Developing a TRK inhibitor or a ROS inhibitor is a small
indication. So this requires a lot
of efforts. I
can tell you that when you believe in the drug, you
tend to have a global development.
With our
G12C, we ran clinical trials, 14 clinical
trials, three pivotals, and we
recruited more than 3,000 patients.
And this was in 25, 30 countries. So very large
effort and investment. So I believe this is
why I think what we are discussing,
I believe that we are going in the same direction.
We need a more efficient development.
We need a development that can be faster, that can give us, if we
believe the drug is a drug, what Tim is telling, I think
together with the regulators, we need to have a
time that is acceptable because this can also cut the
costs and bring the drug quicker to the patient.
I think there's definitely opportunity to have more
engagement with the agency, with real-time review of
data, particularly when it's really very
differentiated from what we've seen and what we expect.
There are pilots ongoing at the FDA
for this very issue on a rare disease.
But I think it's underutilized in oncology
because there have been many initiatives that we've undertaken
in oncology to expedite review. But from a developmental
standpoint, I think it's very helpful to be able to interact and engage with
the agency very early on and frequently
as the data is coming in, as you're encountering long lines, as you're seeing
very different data to really
figure out what the regulatory and clinical strategy will
be. And I think we don't utilize that as much as
we could.
Can I just bring up this concept that we had of breakthrough therapy and
where it came from and how it has been misused?
Okay. Breakthrough therapy came out of the BRAF story,
okay? That was right after those drugs came out
because we said, "Well, we have to move things differently
when we have really therapies that are a breakthrough,"
in quotes. Now, what happened to that concept
was what is a breakthrough? And it got defined as
something that is better than available therapy pretty much, right?
And that ain't a breakthrough because something better than
available therapy could be a PSF, a 10%
improvement in a PFS or something like that, or a 10%
improvement in a response rate. But really, there's a difference, and I
think we've used this term internally when we were discussing
breakthrough therapy, which has kind of been diluted at this time
versus transformative therapies.
And
what we're talking about here is really a transformative therapy.
And the concept of the breakthrough therapy when we had it was that it was going
to be an all hands approach to get these drugs out as
quickly as possible. And I think we have to revisit the original
concept of what that breakthrough therapy principle
was. And it's really kind of got diluted in the agency as
long as I had been there, and Lola might want to comment on it, too.But
it lost its oomph, so to speak, because we're really not talking about
breakthrough therapies. We're talking about marginal improvements over
available therapy. But maybe we should come up with another term
and call it transformative therapies, where there really would be this...
And the whole purpose of the breakthrough therapy was an all
hands-on approach to a transformative
therapy. And I think this is something that the agency
has stated historically that they were interested in doing, and I'm
sure will be also interested in doing this as we move forward with these drugs.
Great point. Transformative or slam dunk, maybe. Okay.
So maybe breakthrough should be reserved to
classes of agent that have a completely different
mechanism of action or chemistry behind them.
Anyway, everything that's been said today, I think it
applies to a number of different classes that are out
there,
BCMA, BT1-
Sure
... HER2, PARP inhibitors, you can go on.
It's the reality of today,
oncology treatment. Now, if there is a
drug that is already approved,
going for a me-too means a biosimilar
or
a generic. The only reason to
have money invested in developing that
is the cost to the patient at the end.
We have seen there has been a lot of
smiling when speaking in favor of this
argument. But I think that in the title of today,
I don't like much the word collide.
I would like see the word cooperation because it helps a
lot to start with the starting point, which
is the patient. Okay? If you start with the
patient, you can ask the following question.
Okay, if there is a drug that is already approved,
that is the standard of care. But
there may be situations that are slightly different.
And today you have alluded
to the different molecular
mutation that might happen. This has been discussed also
yesterday in the resistance plenary session for KRAS.
You can think of a situation where you have
one particular drug, or even better, because this has been
alluded by you before, a combination of
two experimental drugs that has the potential
to offer a big advantage for the patient.
Now, the bigger question historically has been,
Rick is mine, what is the contribution of each
component for... And here again, I
don't make a
plea in favor or against. I'm only saying that
in the presence of clinical results
that are significant and in the presence
of a thorough rationale
for a combination of two experimental agent,
maybe there is a possibility there to proceed with an
approval, but then mandate, perhaps after the original
approval,
further work to elucidate the contribution of each agent.
Maybe there are preclinical model that can help
into that. But then I wanted to ask also about or make a
point about
the me-too of drugs that don't exist yet.
So if there are several companies that are
after the same mutation,
maybe with different
molecules, with different chemistry,
again, who does the work of sorting out
what is in the best interest of the patient?
In my simple mind,
this should be the job of the NCI or the job of
an entity that has
the primary responsibility to take care the
public health. Okay? But as Rick
said, we are in a free society, so that
means to me that the sponsor that
engage in developing drugs
knowing, because with today communication, everybody knows
what everybody else is doing. You don't need the CIA
to find out what's going on. You just come to ACR.
Then their responsibility is to
decide to invest that money in doing that type of
effort, and they take a risk. Thank you very much.
That's the job of drug developers.
Thank you very much. Thank you very much.
So,
we're at time. So, I want to be respectful to this
room as well. So I totally agree with you.
We want to change the title, right? From collision to collaboration.
If I can just summarize everything that's been discussed today, and I
thank all of our panelists and my co-chair and all of you for being
here. We want good drugs. We want the best drugs.
We want transformative drugs. We want platform
studies with a common control arm, potentially.
We want to move away from randomized trials for these slam dunks, for these
transformative treatments, and maybe that's the kind of thing that we need to talk
about right now. I think it's a real opportunity.
But finally, and most importantly, we need to put patients at the
center of all we do and think about how this really
truly impacts our patients and how we can get better
drugs to our patients as quickly as we can.
So with that, I'll bring the session to a close.
Thank you very much, everyone, for being here. Thank you.